[Music]
i normally don't even like to warn you
because i like for you to cringe and i
think it's funny
however
i am going to actually warn you marsh
this is going to be the cringiest video
you're ever going to see okay uh okay
and if i'm wrong after this you go no
royce that was not the cringiest video
and i will apologize to you okay all
right here you go i will say nothing
please watch i got starvies i got sir i
don't even like coffee but i guess i'll
try it
delicious now let's see what goodies
await me in here oh a cake globe wait
cake pop
it appears to be a perfect sphere nice
it kind of looks like a turd
first bite incoming
delicious
yep this is numbs activate happy dance
i got service
so that's a dude right
that's a girl
i found we found her channel and
everything this morning um
what do you think
life material right marge mars let me
ask you a question you know was i wrong
about this being the cringiest video
you've ever seen i want to address that
okay
royce
made some really grandiose claims
and as somebody who has
tried the three of us together and even
even on our own separate starships have
traveled just yes every corner delta
quadrant the gamma quadrant we're
everywhere i didn't have a lot of faith
in your claim yeah
that was one of the most uncomfortable
things
i've ever watched
so she thinks she's like funny
taper made this
start
oh the chat
the taper's too [ __ ] good he's very
good he's too [ __ ] good
he's been killing up for a clip channel
too
um
[Music]
this is would you agree
who is this we need to know well her
name i'm glad you asked her her name is
of course you have a check mark and as
many subs this night yeah yeah well
here's the thing here's why though
she just made her youtube channel six
days ago she has a million tick tock
followers
okay um that's that's why but why
because
i'm going to be writing disney movies
uh retards here you got what are your
thoughts to five all right wait a minute
this is not the right filter wait will i
ever learn to not embarrass myself
probably not
if i were to guess
i blame zoe de chanel again and i know i
bring it up a lot but it bring you you
have to blame zoedition for this right
this is her fault i'm so pilgrim but
those two things together
yeah but this isn't even
you know she wants to be a dude and she
wants to be jim carrey she's trying to
be funny-faced jim carrey and that women
are not
well women are not funny but women are
not funny especially when they try to be
dudes they're not funny you know
especially when they try to be like
bonnie
yeah but who's funnier than self sarah
silverman except a bunch of dudes except
a bunch of dudes [ __ ] yeah norm
look she wants to be jim carrey it is
her name is
bianca
scaglione gaglione by the way yeah and
ladies
you gotta understand there are some
funny women out there right but then you
got to make the trade off right because
if you're gonna the all the funny women
i've ever met in my life and that means
from the bottom of my heart
are the most awful
awful human beings you've ever met
god i agree i agree 100 who's funnier
than miami milf in the chat no and she's
a terrible person terrible person
she's a horrible person she's a horrible
person so you know yeah so but some of
you want to be like quirky and be a cool
you know i'm i'm cool and norm normal
but also i'm funny no you also have to
be dead inside and you're not dead
inside dead inside yeah you understand
ladies that comedy for many people is
just like people that are naturally
funny people nine out of ten of them are
riddled with self-loathing and guilt and
existential dread and it's all defense
mechanism
i am never funnier than when i am at the
hospital or the dentist right or
anywhere where i'm [ __ ] terrified of
pain or death
a plane that like [ __ ] is starting to
get a little shaky all of a sudden i'm
missed a party animal i can't stop me
can you pretend this [ __ ] studio was
a dentist office once in a while then
you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'll give you some highlights magazines
[ __ ]
you know you gotta you gotta put a fish
tank in the [ __ ] corner yeah you
[ __ ] piece of garbage
yeah you know what i mean let's get
ladies just you're not you know you
don't have existential dread you're like
ah
like you know guys will be like oh [ __ ]
man i'll never reach the heights of the
the men that came before me who came so
much closer to god both in time and in
their [ __ ] and in their acts and then
women are like
this isn't fair i want to kill more
babies let me kill more babies
all right what'll it be let's see what
we've got zootopia
yeah i'm gonna have to put this at five
since i'm not a gen alpha let's see what
we have next
hmm this one's going to get a three
because i love cronk but i don't really
like yi's mother i don't know what that
means um i'm assuming it's disney movies
i don't know
uh virgil you have kids maybe you know
what that means so she's not funny but
she's also she looks rough yeah that's
the other thing
like
okay first off
shut up um this is her like thing right
like
she like does she have hairy pits no no
that's actually it's a bit it's a bit
it's a bit everything's a bit would you
do one of these
why did i even bother coming today
hi
i haven't even shaved oh oh my gosh
what she's also really not pretty you
know now that you see the angles
i just
you know she's one you know she's one of
these [ __ ]
that's just always on to you know what i
mean you know she's got to be one of
them [ __ ] you can't even go out to
dinner with your friends well let's pick
a random guy because she's gotta always
she's always performing or trying out
how am i supposed to go to a jousting
tournament for 37 hours if i can't even
get a trenta but i'm still going to
drink it and seriously you're you're not
jim carrey stop bro she
you know you could tell right that she's
one of those ones she's always trying
too hard
and then there's like because like even
you and me like we'll go out like you
know sometimes you're having drinks
everybody's being funny but you never go
out and try to be funny you just go out
you hang out you know whatever but like
you and i have never tried to do bits
no she's the type no i would [ __ ]
tell you to stop immediately
stop doing a character
still going to drink it and seriously
don't even think about judging me with a
straw i have a condition a condition of
being epic
caffeine
bro she's not like the other girls no no
no she's absolutely no she's worse yeah
she's definitely
that's the problem you're right ma'am
you're not like other girls you're
[ __ ] worse
do you want you scaglioni
do you know how much
watching a video of a chick like this
makes you appreciate like just dating
just just a regular basic [ __ ] that
does hair for a living and pays her
bills
and takes care of her responsibilities
and isn't trying to do jim carrey rubber
face bits at [ __ ] dinner but it's
falling you know like it's not even that
she's doing that it's like falling flat
it's terrible i well it's not falling
flat on tick-tock because everybody on
there's a [ __ ] yeah and if you read
the comments comments honestly i was
going through the comments it's all
other women
saying how funny she is